today's topic so we had a uh
ig live where we accepted calls from
fans and this person particularly
happens to be from her city she was
super civil super cool made a suggestion
that she'd heard from other people to us
so i'm gonna play it and again once
again not mad at her at all even though
i vehemently disagree with what she was
saying in this video um
i think she was fantastic and if we ever
grab coffee it's gonna be mad cool all
right but i want to play this
well actually for me my first video
actually that i watched with you guys
was the one where you guys were talking
back about a girl who was saying the age
consent should be 25
yeah you disagree with what we said
no no i did not disagree and that's why
that's what shocked me because most of
the feedback that i get from that about
people talking about you guys it's all
negative and then when i watch it myself
i was like it's true what they're saying
but then um
have you guys ever considered getting a
third party to kind of be kind of like
the buffer in it okay about you're
saying no for sure not like new just
maybe speak on it
okay no
you're laughing because i
i lost it at that time didn't i a little
bit i i wasn't like yelling
from time to time you lose it
but it's okay hold up it's okay i lost
it but i didn't like yeller scream i was
just passionately arguing yeah which is
fine it's not yeah i didn't start saying
it you blue haired blue there was
nothing crazy but then even yeah yeah
and i'm going to explain
the term is a bit strong it's a strong
lose it isn't uh i got a little heated
it got a little bit spirited during the
debate man that water was everything god
damn let me say this
i've received this comment so many times
why don't you guys add a female voice
why don't you guys add a super like
you know safe space like i've had that
commentary so many times and the reason
why it irks me
and why it's always bothered me when i
heard these comments is
whenever men have their spaces where
they get to talk and speak on an
unfiltered manner there's always a group
of people who feel the need to
infiltrate a voice from the opposition
into male-dominated spaces and i find it
extremely distasteful already because
when it comes to male-only spaces in the
media where people can speak unfiltered
i'm not necessarily talking about
youtube nowadays but i'm just talking
about like
television or even before the podcasting
space just like radio there weren't too
many places where men could speak
unfiltered about a lot of their thoughts
or their problems and so
when i see things like the view the talk
all these other female dominated spaces
i thought it was so distasteful that the
moment that male dominated space would
pop up i would always see this need to
either get rid of these spaces or
place a woman on the panel or the group
or the duo to
balance out the discussion me and preach
created this platform right to talk
about a lot of thoughts and ideas we had
do so in a humorous way we get used to
our dynamic it's cool to add someone
else would break up the synergy that we
have it would completely change what
we've created thus far and also we just
don't feel like it's necessary this is a
space where you get to hear the
perspective of us too
and if you want to hear maybe a wider
panel there's a lot of platforms for
people to do that but why is it that
whenever these kind of spaces start to
get created it's like how can we insert
women in these kind of talks and i'm
like why is this necessary why can't you
just come to here maybe you hear
opinions that you don't like or that you
don't drive or you think are too
male-centric and then you go to a
female-centric platform and go and enjoy
that to balance out your life why does
everything need to have perfect
representation right i wouldn't go to
like ben shapiro's show and be like man
you should get a leftist to sit beside
you and you guys have constant back and
forth not everything has to have duality
i feel like when it comes to male spaces
where you get to speak unfiltered people
always be like guys talk about your
problems talk about your views be open
and all this stuff and then when we are
you always find people try to infiltrate
and like curtail the way men speak and
the way they engage in communism i wish
that men should be more open about
themselves like they should open and we
open more than you want a woman in there
that's why we shut the [ __ ] up
it's like you want us to open up for the
minute we do
you wanna yeah but you're not thinking
about it right no i'm just thinking
about it it's just crazy but you know
the thing is
people like to preach to their own choir
that's the thing they want to be around
them people and be like yeah you think
that yeah i think that and then circle
jerk each other they [ __ ] and you
like that yeah i like what you're doing
you like what you're doing
the same way as you i think the same way
you're [ __ ] jerking around each other
but that doesn't challenge your views it
doesn't so if you don't like what you're
saying or saying just think about why
we're wrong and come up with a good idea
or
work on
finding a better way to to have a better
discourse because sometimes you know
it's going to challenge your views and
that's the whole point i can't believe
that in 2021
10 haven't changed things haven't
changed in 21 you want 2021 because you
[ __ ] keep talking to each other
you don't talk to other people that
don't have the same views as you
you don't sit around like okay yeah well
i disagree and just disagree on a no on
a relaxed chill basis that's the thing
you can't you just start with the same
people that are in the same choir that
are the same the same thing oh yeah i
think you're right i think you're right
yeah we're right okay
if you stay here and you keep on
disagreeing with us
you're always hearing like i disagree i
disagree we need to bring a woman so
that the views are the same as mine no
build
better
arguments
or build your own platform don't bring
don't bring another person that's going
to have the same views as you bring
better arguments so that we can have
a chat we can talk and we can move
things forward but nah your
[ __ ] keep talking and that's
not a message to the left that's not a
message to write both you [ __ ]
do this [ __ ]
everybody does this [ __ ] and if you
don't like it here
you don't have to watch god damn it how
easy is how easy is that to be fair
though the only people who ever told me
to add people to this platform
have been
the the feminist types yeah of course
it's only been them of course i've never
had a right one conservative they just
boycotted these stuff they just stopped
nah nah it's always the ladies it's
almost always the ladies one and two
it's almost always like the left-leaning
ladies they're always like you need a
female voice to balance out the dialogue
like no this is not [ __ ] the real
okay here's the reason why it's that
group two is because they love the whole
idea of representation everywhere right
and i'm like do you recognize i can go
as far as you want
you have two dark-skinned women why
don't you get a light-skinned woman to
represent that perspective are two
light-seeing women get a dark-skinned
woman why don't you get an albino woman
to do some representation where's the
native american woman where's the person
who's not able right who's disabled why
don't you get them on the platform as
well to share that kind of perspective
it's like when you get into this kind of
weird identity politics it just becomes
dumb
just create your own platforms create
your own
you know spots where you get to share
your perspective and put it out to the
world and see who resonates with it but
so many people want to be able to just
leech off of things and be like why
don't you have me on your platform why
would i [ __ ] up something that's already
working really well
to please you but we're doing this for
us first
you know it's just listen this is
already a three-man team me preach the
floor we're set
all right we can afford a much better
spot we stay here because we like the
synergy if it ain't broke don't fix it
man but this idea that you guys should
go to every platform and see your like
views reflected what's wrong with y'all
my view has my views have to be
reflected all the time no maybe your
views have to be challenged yeah and
that's what we're trying to do they do
that at comedy shows too
oh well where are the people of color
where are the women where like are the
uh non-binary people like is that how
you
create a good comedy show by looking at
their identity first i'm not mad at
having a diverse lineup i'm cool with it
but if you're just doing diversity for
the sake of diversity like i just don't
care for it and look again once again
i'm not mad at the lady for saying this
this is just more so nobody because
there wasn't like disdain for this kind
of rhetoric everywhere because it was a
good conversation it was a great
conversation yeah but you guys see it on
the patreon if you want to see it
often yeah it often comes out guys if
you guys like the content you guys like
the way we do things if you like this
setup right give a like for the floor
put a little comment for the floor
[Music]
you
i